héros de la droite.
Azeb Wolde-Giorghis.
- Leçodudu Nord,
lance l'animatrice vedette
de Fox News qui, depuis quelques
jours, s'en donne à coeur joie
l l les nouvelles d'Ottawa.
"Les gens au pouvoir au Canada
ont provoqué cette explosion,
dit-elle, à cause de leur
restrictions sanitaires",
en écorchant au passage
le premier ministre Trudeau.
"Le parti libéral est pris
avec ce petit chou ultravacciné,
dit-elle, qui n'aime pas voir
d'autres garçons jouer
dans son carré de sable."
C'est que le mouvement
des camionneurs canadiens
est récupéré par la droite
républicaine, et c'est
Donald Trump qui a parti le bal
il y a dix jours.
"Les camionneurs canadiens,
dit-il, résistent courageusement
au mandat vaccinal illégal."
Le sénateur Ted Cruz
a renchérit
"Ce sont des héros, dit-il,
des patriotes qui manitttt
pour notre liberté."
Dururururs, un ancien fidèle
de Donald Trump, Paul Alexander,
semble faire partie
des organisateurs canadiens.
cocococonseiller en santé
sous l'administration Trump
tentait à l'époque de minimiser
la pandémie et prônaitl'immunit.
Ce mouvement est inquiétant,
soutient cet ancien stratège
républicain. "Il y a des groupes
qui ont des liens avec l'extrême
droite américaine, dit-il,
sur les deux côtés
de la frontière. C'est nouveau
et dangereux", ajoute-t-il.
Et sur les réseaux sociaux,
d'autres convois s'organisent
aux États-Unis.
"Je soutiens à fond
ce qu'ils ont fait au Canada".
Un mouvement qui prend
de l'ampleur partout dans le
monde, Même en Nouvelle-Zélande,
la cause des camionneurs
canadiens fait écho.
En France, elle semble être
repris par les gilets jaunes.
Et ici, le mouvement "DC
convoy", qui compterait
150 000 membres, prévoit
organiser un convoi qui irai
de la Californie à la capitale
américaine d'ici le 1er mars